my name is joël i'm 30 i
grew up in brussels and the european union
the
commission it's all part of my story
when i was little loaded the
car and we went on vacation to
spain to go sailing  at the border
the finger ni was living and the car
talking with my dad
and then we recharge is the car after
we decided to go sailing in
holland
when i was six i saw that they have
knocked down a big wall they made lots of
drawings on it and everyone was
very happy with it I did the same
in my room
oddly enough it couldn't be too much every
day to go to school I passed in
front of the father  then one day they must
have had enough of the decor and
they tore everything down
there must be many of them deciding
because they took a very long time
to agree on the colors in the
end they chose blue  they
rebuilt everything at the same
time new neighbors settled
in  s Italians real people quiet
discreet never one word higher than
the other him before the summer put their name
in the mines for an hour with a glass of
fat easter we gradually redid
them and then there was the  euro and for
adults hell started a euro was worth 40
fchi which was worth about 6
french francs or more or less 2002
half of 3.8 two marks my head my
granny didn't care pascal calculation is
still his bread in  old francs and
my father he sold out saw that he gives
in the parks m finally we
all got used to all costing more but
it was more one in 2004 europe grew
up me too and I left to
discover  monts i closed radius in
denmark thanks to which i now speak
english fluently without a swedish accent
everything was new
to the country the language the culture the first
time i experienced this meaning my parents
when we return to
brussels i had to become  finally adult
of treaty of lisbon les no to
ref  erendum irish french europe
needed me so i did an
internship at the european parliament today
i married a spanish guy and we have two
beautiful kids some spanish and i have
some belgian
my family and i we  are europe
everyday